uma endoscopia digestiva superior também
chamada de esófago gastroduodenoscopia
ou egd é um procedimento que permite que
seu médico Veja a membrana mucosa da
Porção superior do seu trato
gastrointestinal Isto inclui seu esôfago
seu estômago e seu
duodeno
a endoscopia superior é usada para
avaliar sintomas de dor abdominal
superior persistente náusea vômitos
sangramento ou dificuldades para
engolir ela é capaz de precisamente
detectar inflamações infecções tumores
úlceras e outros problemas Possivelmente
presentes o procedimento é executado
usando-se um endoscópio que é um tubo
Comprido fino e flexível com uma lâmpada
e uma câmera de vídeo minúscula na ponta
a câmera transmite a imagem para um
monitor antes da endoscopia um catéter
será inserido e um analgésico e um
sedativo serão administrados sua pressão
sanguínea pulso e nível de oxigênio no
seu sangue serão monitorados durante o
procedimento seu médico irá aplicar um
spray em sua garganta ou fará você
gargarejar com um anestésico local para
amortec você terá que se deitar sobre
seu lado esquerdo e um bocal de suporte
será colocado em sua boca em alguns
casos você poderá receber oxigênio
suplementar através de uma cânula nasal
endoscopias superiores descomplicadas
demoram de 10 a 20 minutos seu médico
irá delicadamente inserir o endoscópio
em sua boca e então irá vagarosamente
cuidadosamente movê-lo através de seu
esôfago até que ele atinja seu estômago
e finalmente seu duodeno você não deve
sentir dor neste momento seu médico pode
periodicamente introduzir um pouco de ar
para esticar a membrana mucosa e
melhorar a visibilidade se seu o médico
quiser coletar uma amostra de tecido ele
pode obter uma ou mais biópsias com o
endoscópio para exame posterior uma
biópsia ajuda a distinguir tecidos
benignos e
cancerosos também é usada para detectar
helicobacter pilor a bactéria que pode
causar
úlceras seu médico também pode usar um
endoscópio para tratar problemas como
úlcera hemorrágica ou estirar uma
estenose ou estreitar o esôfago ou o
estômago Depois do procedimento você
será monitorado até que os efeitos da
desapareçam sua garganta pode ficar
dolorida e um pouco inchada após o
procedimento você deverá ser acompanhado
de volta para
casa